una jornada de paz y reconciliación el
domingo la alcaldía de bogotá organizó
un evento para bajar la intensidad de
las protestas vividas en los últimos
cuatro días la alcaldesa a claudia lópez
prometió una investigación independiente
condenó la masacre y pidió perdón
ofrecemos nuestras condolencias
sabemos lo irreparable de su dolor de su
pérdida
durante el día se celebraron tres actos
una jornada ecuménica con familiares un
concierto y una velatón y cacerolazo
virtual las imágenes de violencia del 9
y el 10 de septiembre parecían quedar
atrás en un lado la policía protegía
estaciones calcinadas del otro lado
vecinos resignifica van el lugar de los
hechos con música y bibliotecas
populares los actos de perdón para
algunos un éxito para desescalar el
conflicto me parece que sirven
completamente porque los días anteriores
no habían sido protestas pacíficas
habían sido momentos en los que han
ocurrido muchos asesinatos como 13 act
asesinatos y realmente pues es muy
preocupante para otros las protestas no
van a acabar y nosotras como ciudadanía
tenemos que reaccionar esto nuestro
estamos pagando sin fuerzas para que nos
maten para que nos dejen sin estudio
sin salud sin vivienda sin trabajo digno
de hecho este domingo una marcha
céntrica volvió a tener disturbios
policiales a pesar de la jornada de paz
y reconciliación muchos consideran que
este día llega antes de que se hayan
producido funerales de los fallecidos
así como de misiones o de instituciones
en los mandos policiales y
gubernamentales